I'm very excited to introduce the next
speaker professor Yan chobe professor B
is a principal investigator in the IDG
McGovern Institute at Beijing Normal
University and she's a chun-hyang
professor in the state's key Laboratory
of cognitive neuroscience and learning
she got her PhD in the Department of
Psychology at Harvard with Alfonso
karamatsu and her work focuses on the
functional and neural architecture
associated with concepts to this end she
uses cognitive neuropsychological and
neuroimaging techniques including early
on a fascinating case study of cognitive
mechanisms leading linked to writing of
Chinese characters today she's going to
overview the Beijing Normal University
and the title of her talk is the science
of learning at Beijing Normal University
today I'm speaking my direction
professor Lee who can't be here because
of visa problems so if you are director
of McGovern Institute you are more lucky
a higher chance of having problems but I
do appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you to each this uart BAU McGovern in
the community and it's a challenge for
to see her will and Norma
in two days alright so where did it
start it started 2010 when Laura and
Hugo took their first visit just eight
kilobytes of cognition or Sandler Nia
being you and they locked us enough to
come back two days later to meet with
the president the State Council vice
premier I think invent got things
rolling a year later the Institute was
formally established and we have been
occurred through the board meeting every
year since and this is your pager Nomo
and our own Institute so this is our
local community the Corp I still and
their lab member saying hi to you from
Beijing all right I feel them here
sitting in the audience in our research
I think it resonates really well with
the two McGovern directors here at MIT
then we carry we covers a wide range of
research matters computation approaches
and you'll actual like to physiology in
your imaging and different bring in
cognitive levels looking at different
hiring order completion in more basic
perceptual problems and especially with
a focus on learning and development so
it's very happy that I'm speaking after
Rebecca and are looking at different
kind of human models in animal models
so veneno has a very strong tradition of
education so I'm going to share with you
one of the central themes of the work
with you it's you ever sent learning in
how to help learning when we talk about
learning we really talk about many many
different things so for learning we can
increase the percentage of the ability
being able to see well or hear well we
can learn new associations between two
different things or you bet we can learn
about episodic issues like this and when
and we can learn about different kinds
of knowledge like learning a new
language learning music clearly sports
really mass or semantic knowledge about
her world and we also learn about social
rules like this is the emperor's new
clothes so we can see where we can in
the same world that somehow the social
route how is not to speak about it so
all these things require learning and we
have done every aspect of it using mouse
models monkey models and longer pieces
you're imaging in different groups and
individuals so I'm going to present one
two studies across the slices I hope
it's not too much but to give you a
sense of flavor what's going to happen
all right I'll start with the most basic
aspect I'm starting with perception
because poor guy again woody this is his
work he come so I'm ordering him first
so perception is very important for some
of survival if you're not good you can't
see a leopard here you so that's very
bad for us like premise and apparently
through training you can't see it so
with training people are better at
perception like detecting the count or
seeing things that like local contrast
the key question is what happened me
Mike how does it work what's the neural
basis for perception learning
and a long debate is whether it's be
pleasing the first pastor on sensitivity
at a vision or a leader reality
efficiently so news lab did this by
recording from the primary visual cortex
we won using material actuals when the
monkey bread is so slow learning the
monkey has to has to say whether there's
a straight line okay through learning
they can do these pops what it meant so
they found basically something's
happening beam already the first part of
the cortex when the visual signal
calcium so this is a cross days the
neuronal population to coding accuracy
of the neuro rebalance you can see
through training is better it's getting
better just looking at the neural Barham
pattern you can see followed by great
interest rate like there and such
decoding other secrets with behavior
well so said be one your eyes already
shaved by the he's training but
interesting me if you unpack through
time if you look at a time course the
first component about forty milliseconds
it's not affected by training it's a
later response about another 40 years
six milliseconds later the training
induce a difference so it seems that
maybe the first response can all be
changed but the readout process
they also did it on local contact like
you are supposed to see which lines
different so after training become very
very good and again here they replicate
the previous finding such that the early
component is not effective but the later
one however this is published in science
there's always extra complication so
when they break down the trials by good
trials and baptize they found that even
the early component seems to be changed
so you know good hires the neural firing
even for the early component becomes
stronger becomes it's more efficient if
guiding your behavior so they are still
debating and now this interplay
complicated interface you can bottom-up
and top-down processes ok we learn about
perception
what about learning to remember what you
perceived so this is Jewish work they
asked people very simple tasks like to
look at a bunch of places look at about
the words you supposed to remember who
you have seen or what words you have
learned what I found was there a very
good predictor of which thought which
place or words being remembered later on
is how similar the neural pattern
activates a neural activity patterns or
across the repetitions so suppose I
still are a few times so each time if my
neural response patterns are very
similar I'm going to remember well
if Jim is several times it's not very
similar I'm going to forget her so the
newer part is yours new pattern predicts
a remember process in their later work
they keep seeing this you using
different kind of techniques so this was
combining stimulation technique in eg
they found that not only the spatial
pattern of your neural response is
important but also the temporal pattern
it's winter fine together and
furthermore if you stimulate your ladder
prefrontal cortex you can change it
helps that spatial temporal neural had a
similarity and then lead to better
remembering so pipe dream anything the
prefrontal if you want to learn
something that's probably a good
strategy in this recent work they just
published is that this animal is not in
not only effect place a road during your
learning phase but thats menarche be
turned on learning the encoding stage in
the retrieval stage also plays a very
important role so again you ask people
to learn much of words and in the
condition where there's not very good
similarity in the visual cortex during
the learning part in the retrieval heart
it leads to false memory it's like oh
maybe have learned this word but you
actually did it
it happens well for the visual cortex
they're learning in the receiver part
the neural pattern does not okay
so the that first two part of perceptual
learning episodic learning the
similarity is the neural response
pattern be important we also made
progress in identifying the structural
basis of learning so this is chocolate
chunks work that they look at on your
circus so they use up to genetics and
European physiology techniques and mouse
models and firstly they showed that they
discovered a direct pathway from lateral
at her anal cortex selectively trans
person that we synaptic information to
hippocampus e1 that was not found before
and this direct circuit is necessary for
learning the Association yeah it's the
core of fracturing associations of
learning so if in this mouse this direct
circus is knocked out these mouths are
not going to be able to learn to
associate one order with the water
report they're not going to be they're
just new Association okay so very
different things like learning about
Association episodic perception the
mouse and monkeys and humans but we keep
seeing some similar convergence like
there's interplay between top bottom-up
and top-down or encoding chief oh it's
happening makes a big difference and the
new I had a snarky seems to be a very
key role in predicting behavior how well
you learn and we also keep discovering
this new structure of circus as opposed
to the relationship between misdirecting
in the function of harness minority we
don't know yet these are the things that
we're talking about in luck
okay so when we talk about learning
outside of this room also after the
psychology community people talk about
learning death like learning a new
language namely learning new knowledge
journey MA and we have done a lot of
work on dust2 I start with then reach
their need to read Chinese so learning
Chinese is hard even for Chinese people
I have a kid who's starting school I was
like this is hard
how did I learn so what's the cognitive
basis to support this learning to read
development so in this study a professor
Washu they followed 294 children
starting from age 4 for 8 years and
every year they'd set them on many
things what the discover was that I
think about messages to the ability
before you learn to rate in this case
the celebrity awareness is how we're you
aware of the slab edge structure when
you hear Chinese is a very good
predictor of how well you are aware of
the morphological structure in a Chinese
dentist after you learn to read okay so
the companying the auditory process
before you learn to read seem to be very
important and if you have a brain
abnormality in this case if these two
particular pathways are not as well
developed so the compared children with
dyslexia in China in controls they found
that these people have less well
integrity in these two pathways and the
integrity of these pathways associated
with partial processing and
morphological processing respectively
and actually another word in
collaboration between routine you know
lab in the library at MIT they were
providing some conversion evidence for
both dyslexia and autism having problems
with this there's particularly if you're
longing to noon or facility but
okay so we had it's hard to read and we
have reading dyslexia how do we fix this
well pressure that's already is I'm
going to a little bit more detail so
this is a joint work by about decimals
lab in language in our Institute so you
take compared training with music
learning piano in learning to read in
groups and also go to groups and then
look at how affects children's ability
to process all these works what they
found was that with the music training
group it's even better then they're
learning to record um enhancing the
ability to do all the traditional paths
and furthermore look the piano girl has
a stronger neural response to audition
kills in that neural response correlates
with behavior I I'm not sure I told it
you got tell this right well okay you're
not kind of judging face it's always
challenging to talk about other people
sorry okay so learning piano is good for
for a word processing so that's all a
giant motor right
your new person visual perception is
also good so in this study it's very
cool so they asked dyslexic children
just to do the basic of visual
perception or just to look at patterns
and detect them and it turned out his
children improved on reading fluency so
they did more training on anything the
quest take they didn't you even want
honesty so I said really really using
Bob's word her genius like her complex
system that intersects with all these
basic sensory processing systems okay so
we were when we learn to read we not
only try to learn the sound of the words
but we also learned the meaning of the
word the million versus really the
knowledge we have about the whole world
you look at the meaning of these words
cup rainbow in freedom to JT 14 and I'll
tell you so we were also curious about
how important this sensor path
processing
I in learning about the meaning of the
word all the knowledge about the world
so we can't contract it congenitally
blind subjects and controls to see how
important mission is many people work
ambitious if we know it's very important
but it turned out it's not that
important for something like in this
case we will ask people to judge about
the shape of the car and you think okay
to plump people of course know the shape
because they can touch right so yes it
turned out they know the shape very well
similar to sided but not obviously in
the brain both flying inside it has this
information stored in the so called
visual cortex in a if your temporal lobe
so we talk about visual cortex but it
doesn't matter whether I mean
preparedness information through eyes of
through touch as long as it's about the
same kind of knowledge okay but it's a
different thing for rainbow because you
feel can see rainbow we can touch hey
with custom AOH we can play with it
right how do we record it it turned out
for this part of the brain where more
object knowledge is stored rainbow for
blind it's like freedom for sighted it
becomes more object well we can still
know everything about it it's just out
there so we think that it's learnt based
on language based on verbal relations
through language be there anything but
the way that the brain stores say it
becomes in the abstract part of the
brain so it's sensory important for
learning language yes and no it's not
necessary to learn all these skills what
the facts were in how the information is
door okay how about I just make that
well because that's my own word
like everything else we were curious
about the structural basis of all these
knowledge versus the representation so
looking at higher cognition is hard so
we took advantage of the leisure model
in the brain I mean a human so stroke
patients patients with tumor resection
TBI and we identified a 3 major what
Martha passed a very long ranged being
necessary for these so if you have a
lesion here if your lesion is back that
will lead to tooth metric deficit in the
size of the lesion correlates with
semantic severe deficits virtually
furthermore using machine learning
representation signal analysis loss of
decoding approach we found that the
pattern of your lesion in these what
matter charts can predict or decode the
pattern of your symmetric deficits
suggesting that all these fine knowledge
might be stored in these long rich
connectivity pathway seriously you know
judging face from back ok learning about
language reading some in technology so
what's the common thing again we see
tight interaction with sensory processes
higher of cognition sensor processing we
see the reading the meaning the sound
the morphological processing are both
supported by different kinds of long
range finally learning about social I
was very inspired about Rebecca's talk
about social because huh it's good to
help me to explain so this is in my in
that email mass work of very brilliant
young GI Iman huh
so she was always curious about social
learning social cognition and I'm only
present here to teach as many good work
only have timing for - so why is
learning about social information so
they asked people to do a very simple
estimate of something bad to you then
they give you about you finishing the
social group
the probability of what's going to
happen in a social context and then they
asked people how well they learn this
information to modify your own behavior
it turned out people have a very strong
positive bias if the feedback is given
in a positive way they drive very fast
these immediately changes their own
behavior so if there is something bad
they don't care it's like they're
playing dry up to but it's not gonna
happen
the conversation we had yesterday so
people are very biased towards positive
social information to change their own
behavior furthermore if you give them
our toss in apparently a very classical
social moderator through NATO spray it
changes their behavior but again only on
the positive information they become
even better and taking in the positive
social and what about making complex
social decisions so this is a very
simple task they're so common so they
ask people to church if you just simply
give people money you give something
some money to yourself in others and
whether this is a good way or bad way
and it's a social decision or judgment
there varies by people it goes back to
Bob's or the point of precision so what
they found was that whether you judge
this to be a good allocation strategy it
totally depends on your own internal
reference point so they did something
very smart they asked people to give the
best job did you think and then lay this
on this relative space what they found
was there's a huge individual difference
some people are more selfish they cares
more about fairness
some people are totally self-centered I
just won't be to get more money and when
the new information comes in is there
this that comparison of the stimuli and
that there is very different internal
revenue point
that angle that error signal determines
their behavior whether they think this
is a good plan or battlin so it does
huge individual barriers what needs to
be taken into consideration when we see
a behavior in furthermore that error
signal that cosine bar is encoded in
amygdala activity so if that beta is
strong they actually need a meteor
activity strong and furthermore again
the check is if you keep them asked us
in it enhanced a newer amygdala
representation in then changes your
behavior to more pro-social you become
less self-centered your move towards
fairness I think everyone should just
take
don't make decisions when you have
higher like pregnant pregnancy okay the
final part of learning in social context
again it goes back to Rebecca's point
learning for a self in the in the social
context by teacher is totally different
so in this study Lu Xiang Ning they
scanned using nurse F nurse to people
the student and the teacher
simultaneously to see what's the
relationship between these two people's
brain that's related to learning in the
social context okay long story short
again neural had a similarity between
the teacher in the student is very
important but it's amazing there's a
time lag so how well the teacher is
newer model predicts just students new
pattern about a 10 to sit calm in a
second if they can predict well then
their learning becomes more successful
it took me a long time to understand why
like see because the prediction is
really based on high level you two
internal structures it's like the stew
teacher has to be very sensitive of the
communist state of the student in to
modify it accordingly modify how to
teach accordingly okay so I'm trying
very hard to get some coherent message
out of all these so this why I said okay
positive bias error signal encode
amygdala affected by oxytocin and then
your parents emeriti across individuals
affects knowledge transfer going back to
the to the early kinds of learning study
all right so what's the conversion
what's it diverges still management
console learning different aspects
different levels but I hope you're with
me that you see something pops out like
your openness morality is important for
perception episodic semantic knowledge
income and structure pieces many are
related with long-range connectivity
patterns the big question is what's that
the main general mechanisms of all this
kind of learning can we use some of the
mechanisms to enhance learning of
helping people to learn better with
language to help people with learning
difficulties so these are the heated
discussion we have in a lot we're hoping
to test some of the findings with Mouse
and like learning knowledge or the
effects of oxytocin learning different
kinds of things and all these findings
is part of the progress report addressed
to the support of the cabin so where are
we going this from this we're going long
it's you know going on get you know it's
like a no-brainer if you're interested
in learning well I have to us put more
slicing in we're guided by some basic
sized findings we had in on don't worry
it's going to the finished Mercer so you
again the mouse model with hidden are
getting more and more understanding
about the the importance or the
mechanisms of critical period in
different moment phrases its - shall we
Thomas birth they show that okay this
inhibitory GABA regulates the panel
humor synchronization of neurons when
you have a bit remote just firming with
it it only happens during the critical
period it does not happen before I have
an object so something about the sensor
does he do that time and also inhibitory
interneurons are involved in regulating
the onset of that critical period how
that so average inhibition system seems
to matter very much so how does work in
this recent paper they found that two
different kind of
between neurons through the lick with
the excitatory neurons deep are
differently drive slow oscillations in
fast consolation such as together that
balance can produce or maintaining the
more temporal structure of local
activity connectivity so this is very
basic magazine less strong to the human
level directly we were talking about
scanning brain if it's brain
so this is infants are from yonkers work
group through collaboration with
pediatric hospitals
this is infant preterm infant so there
are about thirty one week to forty two
weeks post menstrual so this is our
normally they should see you in the
belly of the mother
so they scan their brain and look at
this so this is every two weeks from
search for forty weeks and the color
shows the functional connective strands
of the region so you see this drastic
show emergence of the functional
connected hubs in the primary sensory
motor systems it's developing its timing
hard to develop all these connections
with the rest of the brain and it's
doing so by increasing spaced
specifically the short range in middle
less functional connectivity so we talk
about critical period so these are the
critical period of the system
so we had started this very ambitious
national consortium of children studies
and it's part of the big China brain
project that I found was talking about
so it's also part of the admission of
that big China burn project and being
you is playing a very leading role in it
so right now there are 22 institutes in
China participating already we have
constructed platforms for various data
banks for Chinese children bring in
behavior in also genetic data developing
protocols for longitudinal follow-ups
aiming to understand these various
ambitious scientific issues like
biomarkers such a curious the effects of
mission ownership I don't fake but this
is a big project
so the PAP forms are already so there we
already constructed a recently published
bring atlas for Chinese children
specifically so this is based on the
imaging data from search 328 Chinese
children aging for ranging from 6 to
travel and it to build a brain tablet
that you can use as a reference point
includes the age specific map and also
sex specific map it's important to do
this because when which contrast is
Chinese template with the NIH pediatric
template you see interesting differences
with the frontal especially frontal lobe
and also when you analyze Chinese
children's brain data if you normalize
to this address you get a better
sensitivity and predictability
compared to being normalized to the NIH
tempo
in the final so the platforms for the
image analysis choose prison we develop
various kinds of way like how you
scorpion go Lance group they developed
analyzes choose for looking at complex
pre network data for visualizing brain
networks that's already used by a
hundred laps around the whole world and
not only applicable for human data
different kind of em each EEG human data
but also mouse and monkey data ok I hope
you got a sense of the thing we did when
we are not in a lab working we try to
play with other it's a change Institute
so this is one of the retreat we hosted
you know zhuhai campus it's a very nice
southern tank and next time you could
host it there again please calm is
really Pleasant and I will end with an
extremely short video from eight years
ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was our president she don't
speak in the background
thank you for Pat Laura and the winter
is leaving the spray is coming we have a
bright future
that's very applicable for today and I
want to thank you especially to Pat -
Laura - Hugo - McGovern foundation the
big become a community thank you thank
you so much for that fascinating
overview do we have any questions
so the the instrument you referred to is
the piano if you were to substitute that
with a violin or flower flute or guitar
results I know exactly how to answer
that question Bob Ellison okay I
actually asked the first author who
always know the more the details have to
work he's she says I was sitting home
how does it work like you need to read
it really tells you about the auditory
input as well why does the piano works
better
she says it's really the precision of
the artistic skills so I guess if you
play the part like piano is very good at
directing that with the Ballia cuz you
have to teach them really well to do
this fine precision of the audition the
pitch judgment so pitch pitch decision I
think is a key
any other questions so what are the key
implications for drastically
transforming the Asian educational
system that's coming out of your
research because I have been educated in
Asia and in Europe and the United States
and I work globally with many young
people that are products of those
educational systems and I'm wondering
what the implications of your research
are maximized if sensory is truly the
key and we have five senses so we
emphasize a few of the senses especially
in Asian memorization based test based
learning are there drastic
transformations coming in the age of AI
that's a very great question I'm hearing
different kind of education styles and
also the AI did you say yeah officially
internal okay I hold in your area of AI
so there's cultural difference education
styles and AI in different senses and
the memorizing so what's my take on this
I have to be very careful you answer
questions like this and I think we have
some very indirect implications like my
works showing that senses it affects how
where you store the knowledge but it's
not necessarily inquiring the knowledge
you're going to store in the brain
somewhere you can quiet
I think Rebecca's work with blind also
showed that right but I think one thing
that's more direct related to education
it's luffa mix work where they were
recording from the teaching the students
and showing you how the the
predictability of the teacher on the
state of the students really matters I
think that has a big thing in the in the
classroom like paging you have like 70
kid in a classroom you can't do that
right here you know you have more
resource to do that so I
so it's more less than teaching style
but the availability of the resources
allowing you to pay more attention to
the individual welcome back to Rebecca's
work like you have to be directing to
the recipient so I think these are the
direct relationship as for AI yeah I'm
not comfortable like I was doing great
question just without thinking too much
I I don't see the direct connection
there yet any other questions I wanted
to hear more about that amazing
longitudinal sample so how old are the
children and how many are there and what
is going to be studied about them it
seems like an incredible opportunity we
have a pie
mention this project because I was
involved in this project since like
almost three years ago as now now the
planning is we already in the pigeon and
also the another city in the south west
of China we have like suicides now we
have like almost like a complete second
time point offer about the 600 from a
600 children from 6 to 12 and these were
expended to over 22 sites across the
whole China and we're going to reach
climbing in next like five years and the
first example could be reached about
20,000 they're planning now for and also
depends on like a Chinese brain project
how much like resources they were going
to and including also the entire
dimension that like we have a behavior
and gene and also have a brain
so the 20,000 means like including gene
and the brain but the behavioral
psychological measurements will be much
larger like the president of our
university already accomplished that
more than like it's about like a tongue
and 100 I think it's a hot how to say
it's like ten hundred 100 100 thousand
for psychological measurements with
behavior me but without the brain for
print like data we're going to reach you
like it
the kind of planes like a 20,000 Hz I
remember we're discussing whether it's
realistic to go under six and we
mentioned your word so I think they're
discussing this is I don't know much
details but further for the Chinese like
children brain project was will be
collaborated closely with ABCD so we'll
proceed to lunch in the poster session
and I'll see you all back here at 2 p.m.
I'd like to thank now all of the
speakers this morning and the audience
for your questions
attention
[Applause]